[Music]
thank you for joining us here welcome
back to the program under sheriff
christopher darcy joining us once again
for mornings with metro good to see you
once again good morning john thanks for
having me so we are well into the summer
now
it is hot outside typically crime goes
up this time of year what should people
do in their homes when they're walking
around town whatever the case may be
to just try and protect themselves keep
themselves safe
yeah obviously i think sometimes in
summer people often let their guard down
they're out later at night they're
walking around
there's just more activity outside so
just always be around be aware of your
surroundings
right try not to walk alone places have
a buddy have a person
that you're with that help keep you safe
are there particular types of crime that
metro sees during the summertime
burglaries robberies things like that
typically we'll see violent crime
increases in in the warmer months
um throughout throughout the united
states we'll see that in a variety of
cities so
i mean we see that as well we're
fortunate though right now our violent
crime
is down 10 really okay well something
that unfortunately doesn't seem to be
going away and that is the issue of
auto pedestrian deaths crashes around
the valley
um it's an ongoing issue uh to try and
address this there have been several
programs and
initiatives around to deal with this but
nothing seems to change
what should pedestrians and drivers for
that matter
what how do they protect themselves how
can we try and get our streets safer
walk around well pedestrian er is really
one of those things that we see occur
quite frequently
we see people crossing the streets and
other than you know marked crosswalks
and at the lights
and in this town there's a lot of
glitter and lights and drivers do not
see you
and you you may come from a city or a
place in america where
the traffic is a lot slower there's just
not as much you know light
and they walk out and unfortunately they
get struck that's why
um you know we try to conduct
enforcement
to make sure that people understand to
cross them our crosswalks
and there's so much again there are so
many initiatives that have taken place
in good faith efforts it seems like by
organizations in town to try and address
this and
make drivers aware make pedestrians
aware
when will it get to a point or is it at
a point now that something more
out front something more critical is
going on and needs to be done
well i know the the legislature changed
the law for uh to make it a civil
infraction right so we no longer stop
rest and
cite people for for jaywalking so we'll
see if that has an impact either way
whether it reduces it or it doesn't and
then we'll you know we'll address it
from there
but i mean that doesn't change some of
the other things that we can cite for
there's other crimes obviously
and things that we can use to help
persuade citizens to make sure that they
stay on the
sidewalk and you know especially if it's
an ongoing issue in the community
it's a law like that might not change
you know how wide the roads are and
where the crosswalks are and
just the mechanism and the
infrastructure that doesn't necessarily
lend itself to
crossing the street safely it really is
education it's enforcement and it's
traffic engineering yeah
and that's really where our partnerships
with the municipalities right the city
and the county that can help us when we
see
accidents in certain intersections we
can make those changes to the
engineering aspect of it
under sheriff christopher darcy we do
thank you for joining us this morning if
you at home have a question for metro
police we'd love to ask them
just submit them submit their questions
on our website eightnewsnow.com
you'll find out if it's answered every
wednesday morning